Good Morning, Hank, its Tuesday. So, remember Brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician Daniel Biss?
He was a friend of mine, and a very successful math professor at the University of Chicago
before deciding to leave that job and run for political office whereupon he eventually became a very successful state senator.
Yeah, so Daniel is now running for Governor of Illinois,
like, complete with fancy campaign ads and everything.
And I have to say, this turn of events is a little surprising to me, because Daniel is the smartest person I know
and Governor of Illinois seems like a
a terrible job.
For one thing, Illinois politics are so dysfunctional that the state regularly has no budget.
And, for another, four of Illinois's past ten governors have been imprisoned for corruption,
an incarceration rate that is, you know, somewhat higher than the one seen among professors of mathematics.
Anyway, what interests me most is that Daniel, deep down, wants to work in government to help people, and because he believes in democracy.
And he's actually been very successful as a state senator.
He led the passage of legislation to increase retirement savings, and a ban on so-called "conversion therapy" for LGBT people.
But, to accomplish stuff, he's had to wade through this vast, gridlocked swamp of US politics,
and also, he's had to attend many, many meetings.
Hank, sometimes when we talk about politics, or the news, people in comments will be like, "Why don't you run for office?"
And the short answer is that being a politician means going to meetings all the time, and I hate meetings with a white-hot passion.
Like, when I'm forced to attend a meeting, by far my most common contribution is to say,
"So, are we done, then?"
I usually start saying that like 12 seconds into a meeting, and then repeat it, mantra-like, until finally I am released.
Slight tangent:
The other day, I was playing Ping-Pong with Stan, and I was telling him how happy I am about the Crash Courses in Computer Science and World Mythology,
and he was like, "Yeah, do you want to do some more Crash Course: Literature in the fall?"
And I was like, "Maybe."
And he was like, "We could read 1984, some other-"
And I was like, "Wait a second, Stan, did you just use the magic of Ping-Pong to trick me into a damn meeting?"
So, anyway, more Crash Course: Literature coming this fall.
But, to return to the point, politicians have to attend so many meetings.
Like, say you're running for governor here in my home state of Indiana.
You have to have tons of meetings with rich people to ask them for money,
and then every day you have to have meetings with strangers all around the state to hear their concerns.
Many of these people will disagree with your political positions, and will never vote for you,
and yet you have to listen to them like a grown-up and resist the urge to cover your ears and say,
Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na, Na
And then, you have to shake hands with these strangers, even though human hands are notoriously filthy and handshakes always remind you of that story about someone coming up to James Joyce
and saying, "Can I kiss the hand that wrote Ulysses?", and Joyce saying, "No, because it's done so many other things as well."
And then, if you're good enough at shaking hands and meeting with rich people
and meeting at town halls and meeting with other elected officials
et cetera, literally ad nauseam,
You get to be Governor.
At which point you basically become a professional attender of meetings.
Hank, do you know what the Governor of Indiana is doing right now?
He is attending a public meeting of the Indiana Economic Development Corporation.
I mean if there is a hell and I end up there I will spend eternity thinking:
"Well, at least I am not at a meeting of the Indiana Economic Development Corporation.
So yeah, my hatred of meetings, among other things, would make me a terrible elected official
but that doesn't mean elected officials are terrible.
In fact, the only one I know is among the kindest,
most thoughtful people I've ever met
and no matter your political leanings, you'd be lucky
to have him as your governor.
Now, of course, too many politicians do embody our caricatures of them
but our system of government depends upon Daniel
and the many, many people like him.
People who are passionate and honest public servants
and who are willing to attend many, many meetings so that I don't have to
We desperately need those people in government,
so Daniel, thank you, good luck, I know you're running against a few billionaires
but I believe in you.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
End... Screen. Hey, so you know Self-Care Bunny?
Rosianna's "Self Care Bunny" is now available in beautiful poster form
at DFTBA.com.
Also a lot of you have been asking about the boxes in the background--
I don't know what's in them.
but in a completely unrelated story, as you might know,
there is a scavenger hunt happening.
There's a different riddle every week, it's a little bit complicated...
I'll explain more in the doobly-doo.
But for those of you who like riddles, this week's clue actually IS Self-Care Bunny
Well
Rearranged......